who were your biggest influences would
you say to your style to just just on
some rappership when you were growing up
who were like your top three or four
guys who were like always just if you
put 50 Cent
Gucci Mane
yo got it and don't be all in like
what's up yeah you get from this two
times put all them [ __ ] in one all
them [ __ ] inspired me some type of way
like yeah you know what I'm saying God
it was just a for Memphis like you know
I'm saying were you young and this was
before the internet you know he was on
tvt records and dropping the mixtapes of
DJ Smalls and [ __ ] back in the day yeah
yeah like Three Six Mafia of course like
you hearing that type of [ __ ] like it's
like it's a kid and like I said like a
lot of people don't know about me my I
had a musical family
so like oh like my mama my mama could
sing my my auntie could sing and dance
my uncle could sing and dance so it was
just a musical house like everything was
just always music music music you know
what I'm saying so so you know I grew up
around the music what's the hypnotized
mind [ __ ] like uh did that have like
obviously you know shout out to three
six shout out to Frasier boy shout out
to the chat shout out to Eric
you know the whole [ __ ] little white
Triple Sec triple six how how big of a
uh impact did they have like growing up
just knowing that like there was
somebody else from Memphis that I mean
they were nominated for Oscar you know
what I'm saying like right right right
I mean that would be for the city that
was that was big as hell for the city
like like damn folks then you know the
hustling flow movie like you know what
I'm saying that counter solidified like
the culture of Memphis like we like like
their movie was real like everything
about that movie was authentic like this
Memphis right there it was shot in South
Memphis there's Memphis every day all
day
shout out to uh Terence Howard all-time
performance man yeah I believed it yeah
I believe this [ __ ] this [ __ ] was hard
this [ __ ] was hard like this idea